have you ever realized one of your films
yes we just recently realizes black
coffee to balance so it was on bt
initially i hate we license for three
years on beating they rebreather for
another year would be et and then after
that license would be t we did another
we did a renewal we're not everything
but we license it to the balance TV so
yeah we realizes our projects quite
often
again that's how you that's how the
filmmakers make real money is by
controlling your content not giving your
content way to distributors for over
three years and that's there for every
time you use license your project you
make money off of it if every every
three you know you make money off of it
and it's mostly in the front end of the
deal oh yes oh yeah so what they most
companies what they do is they either
give you something on frontiere or they
pay in increments so they may pray they
say for instance for a year they may
give you they definitely give you
something up front and then they may do
something like every three months it
says all paid off
yeah did the companies ever try to bully
you into certain terms and try to steer
you and say well it's you know it'll be
better if we just wait till the end of
this this contract term and it will give
you big lump sum then or yeah don't ever
believe that unfortunately a lot of
distributors are not honest so they give
you promises that they definitely can't
keep so if so that's what I'm saying
like they their job is to control your
content because they know it's the only
or content or to license your content
for for as many years as possible
because this is how they keep their
company alive and afloat but you know
selling your the ricey of fam to to the
different television networks and things
like that and also what they do they
call it they call it a twenty five
percent distribution fee don't ever do
that
distributors don't like it I mean
distributors they come okay so this is
what happens right they say we will do a
50/50 split so but
we're going to do a 25% license fee so
if you do a 50-50 split with the
distributor but before anybody sees any
money they have to take 25 that means
that they take 25% of whatever is made
of top so what's essentially what is
happening is that instead of doing a
50-50 split they get 75% and they're
giving you 25% that's why you see that
25% distribution fee don't do it at all
because you're not making any not making
any real money and then another thing
you have to be very careful of is the
marketing fee cap off your marketing fee
so some some company some companies said
okay we're gonna spare 80,000 or 100,000
of marketing mmm that's not that's not
gonna happen I'm talking about I'm not
talking about like your big major
studios talk about you know the we
talked about films that I made fun you
know but independent films then go to my
smaller distribution companies so for a
distribution company telling you that
they're spending $100,000 marketing do
not believe they put $75,000 down but
what they do is they do no marketing at
all so they could just do a couple of
posts on social media and they can write
that stuff off so distribution feed and
distribution fee for 25% do not do that
deal do not do the the distribution fee
and do not if you want to do a marketing
fee you wanna you want to make sure that
you know where they give you a list of
where they're gonna market your film at
and not only a list but how much they're
gonna charge like say for instance if
they go on to that they gonna do some
marketing for and inside of the New York
Post or side of a magazine but you want
to know how actually how much they pay
for that marketing you want to know you
just wanna you wanna things out of my
eyes you know or you can cap it off and
say okay just marketing for $5,000 you
know but they I wouldn't I wouldn't do a
deal with a company and they gonna take
25% just distribution fee or they gonna
take
35000 or they have marketing up in
because you would in the reason they do
that is because before you see a dime
they have to recoup that mark anything
that's how they able to that's how
they're able to not pay filmmakers is
because of the marketing which they
never do did you find that out the hard
way I found it out the hard way oh yes
this distribution fee and because I
didn't know again like when I did was
doing I did my earlier films is like you
know the I had to find out the hard way
I was like what the hell is the
distribution fee that means that you
know we charge you 25 percent just to
distribute your film
I'm like no yeah so you do find out the
hard way marketing you're thinking that
you actually think that they're gonna
put marketing into your film but they're
not you know they're gonna do a couple
of social media post and make it always
you know and that's how they get you and
you would never see you would never see
money from your family at all at all and
it's not fortunate
you